ho cominciato la mia carriera da un
programma televisivo una competizione di
cucina da questa esperienza ho capito
una cosa ma lasciato veramente dentro di
me quello che volevo fare da grande e la
scelta di quello che volevo fare da
grande e io facevo tutto un altro
mestiere fino a quel momento è un po di
sconfessione di obama da quando ero
piccolino mi hanno aiutato a capire una
cosa non serve un programma televisivo
per diventare un cuoco neanche un
cantante non si diventa cuochi dopo un
programma televisivo non si diventa
cantanti dopo un talent show
bisogna andare a studiare bisogna farsi
il mazzo
a me piaceva tantissimo la vita di
cucina volevo diventare un cuoco il più
in fretta possibile
volevo arrivare a governare la mia
brigata volevo imparare volevo andare a
testa fissa su una gratella quando
diceva cosa fai amato però così ho fatto
ha scelto forse la miglior scuola al
mondo ce l'abbiamo qui in italia nella
scuola del maestro gualtiero marchesi
che oggi purtroppo non c'è più però e
alma e lì ho passato qualche mese a
capofitto a studiare la chimica degli
elementi a studiare i cibi come
funzionano come rispettare al massimo da
un vegetale una carne piuttosto che un
pesce è subito dopo conosciuto un grande
maestro che è giacinto rossetti un tre
stelle michelin
lui mi ha preso per mano e ma guidato a
conoscere l'alta cucina neoclassiche
francese ho conosciuto lava cucina di
paul bocuse augusto scopi insomma in
questi anni ho cercato di formarmi al
massimo e dopo tempo che passavo in
cucina c'era qualcosa che non mi tornava
i conti non mi tornavano ero a volte
anche infelice e lì è stato forse il
cambiamento radicale nella mia vita dove
mi ha portato oggi perché mentre noi ci
facevamo 15 ore al giorno a fornire un
carciofo cercare di servire al meglio
possibile questo a fogliolina verde a
rispettare un contadino rispettare la
provenienza del cibo stesso
dall'altra parte vedevo questo com'è
possibile come come abbiamo fatto
arrivare a questo punto qua allora io ho
continuato a indagare ha continuato a
ragionare
a cercare di capire come funziona
l'intero mercato e più andiamo avanti
più trovavo queste cose questo qua è un
semplice al gusto di lasagne ha trovato
cose che voi umani non potete immaginare
ve lo garantisco cose che si
ribalterebbe il buon gualtiero nella
tomba
e la conferma di ciò era iniziato andare
più nel profondo
l'ho trovata in sicilia io mi trovavo in
sicilia a girare un servizio per una
trasmissione televisiva non posso fare
nomi se no mi picchiano però elogi non è
questo servizio ed ero raccontare come
funziona la raccolta degli agrumi sono
arrivato in sicilia pensando di trovare
questi alberi maestosi pieni di fruttino
e quello che mi si è presentato davanti
è stato questo tant'è che a primo
impatto velici però a ferrara da
grandine quando viene viene bene però
che quello scherza mica è in realtà il
conto di nomi ha detto magari fosse
stata la grandine almeno un
assicurazione mi avrebbe dato una mano
sapete perché sono caduto in terra le
lance perché il prezzo del mercato era
troppo basso non gli venivano pagati
abbastanza per consentirgli di pagare la
manodopera per raccogliere la frutta e
pio giravo più queste realtà succedevano
giorno dopo giorno
parliamo di circa 50 centesimi al chilo
che gli riconoscevano allora la domanda
è stata ovvia scuse un attimo vado al
supermercato e costano 2 euro e 62 ore
70 al chilo dov'è la fregatura che a
volte addirittura c'è scritto buccia non
edibile perché dove sta l'inghippo e ha
cercato di indagare ancora più a fondo
il fatto è che un pochettino è colpa
nostra è colpa nostra perché ci
riduciamo a comprare le fragole a natale
le fragole a natale non esistono le
fragole ci sono maggio ci sono giugno
cerchiamo di iniziare a ragionare in
quest'ottica perché ci porterà a capire
i perché delle arance ma lo stesso lo
andiamo a trovare negli allevamenti
lo stesso lo andiamo a trovare sui
pescherecci scegliere quello che
mangiamo è veramente molto importante
non solo per un fattore
egoistico nostro per la nostra salute ma
per andare a difendere e coprire questo
io vengo da qui vengono da dove il brodo
si fa consiglio della carota cipolla e
il cappone idea dolini le polverine
magiche che so che c'e la mente tutti in
frigo non si utilizzano è tutta un'altra
cosa è tutto un altro marketing
allora io mi ricordo quando ero
piccolino che andavo nell'orto a volte
prende anche degli scopi cioni dal nonno
perché andavo a zappare
pensavo fosse l'erba in realtà erano i
hradecky perchè devo e lo sa non mi dava
dietro questo era la cura maniacale che
poteva avere il nonno e se ci guardate
tutti i nonni tutti gli ordini tutti le
canne legate con il filo e guardate che
meraviglia
l'insalata così non la compriamo quasi
più
abbiamo le buste perché perché dura di
più ma ci sarà un motivo se dura due
settimane in frigo la busta di insalata
quando questo dopo un giorno sia fiamme
sapete perché si avvia pisce perché
nessuno ci ha insegnato a conservarla
se noi quelli insalatina lì la
raccogliamo con le nostre radici e la
mettiamo a bagno in un vasetto d'acqua e
li diamo ad avere è una pianta dura il
triplo del tempo però fare questo noi
non andremo più ad acquistare l'insalata
di plastica sarebbero che agire qualcuno
non ci guadagna più la differenza tra un
artigiano e alcuni tipi di commercio è
che l'artigiano produce cibo
conoscendo e cercando di regalare
un'emozione a chi mangia il suo stesso
cibo
proviamo a considerare il parmigiano
reggiano gli aceti balsamici grandi
prosciutti l'artigiano che ci sta dietro
a una cura maniacale l'altro tipo di
mercato serve solo per riempire le
tasche di qualcuno
questo è il brodo
questo è il dado da brodo le foglie
esterne brutte dell'insalata che cadono
le prende la mia nonna mi ricordo che le
prendeva e le dava da mangiare
all'arrosto della domenica che era
colori di fianco
oppure addirittura quando si fa il brodo
a casa che rimangono tutti i pezzi dice
cosa facciamo cosa fa la nonna andava a
macinare pangrattato parmigiano faceva
le polpette consumo
magari dei pomodori dell'orto cibi che
ci siamo completamente dimenticati oggi
qual è la città
posizione attuale la situazione attuale
di oggi è che con la scusa della fretta
che dopo andremo a sviscerare anche
questo termine siamo messi così che
riempiamo il nostro stomaco di stereo e
soprattutto quello dei nostri figli di
steroidi anabolizzanti di medicinali che
danno gli animali pensate un allevamento
intensivo di polli è paragonabile
perdonatemi il paragone ma è
paragonabile a una scuola a una classe
dell'asilo cosa succede all'agile
bambini se sceglie ammala 1 cioè lo
sterminio totale il giorno dopo su tutti
a casa con la febbre
i poli sono uguali cosa fanno per non
farli prendere questo tipo di malattia
li bombardano di medicinali c'è un
veterinario che la sembra controllare ma
dove finiscono questi medicinali
gli antibiotici ce li mangiamo tutti noi
dal primo all'ultimo
io c'ho un brutto esempio da farvi ciò
che un po macabro però parlavo con un
becchino e mi ha raccontato che ad oggi
che ha da vari quando li riesumano per
ridurli di dimensioni fanno fatica a
decomporsi
negli ultimi 30 anni abbiamo assunto
talmente tanti coloranti e conservanti
che il nostro corpo ci mette il doppio
del tempo a decomporsi
questo è un dato abbastanza preoccupante
perché poi vediamo le malattie lungo
termine andiamo ad avere un sacco di
dati a nostro favore
qual è il modo per cambiare ci sono due
tre modi semplicissimi io ho conosciuto
durante un altro programma mentre
registrava una ragazza questa ragazza
qua non è non ha 80 anni ha più o meno
la mia età
vedete cosa c'è nel beach 18 sapete che
cos'è e pane semplicissimo lei insieme
al suo papà tutte le sere fanno il giro
con il ducato con il fiorino di tutto il
pane della frutta e della verdura
invenduti a prato nel loro paese
prenderlo tutta questa frutta e verdura
mettono nella betoniera e fanno la zuppa
per i maiali oggi producono uno dei
prosciutti più buoni italiani lo
forniscono al papa e addirittura il
presidio slow food macchiaiola maremmana
non è per fare pubblicità non mi
interessa in questo luogo fare
minimamente pubblicità però questo è un
esempio perfetto di come la cucina può
avere un inizio e una fine circolare che
è una fine non è un inizio perché
qualcuno un giorno disse nulla si crea
nulla si distrugge tutto si trasforma
circa dovrebbe essere questa è la vita
della cucina è quello che dovremo
cercare di fare noi nel nostro piccolo a
casa perché è impensabile che vengano
prodotti milioni di tonnellate di cibo
tutti gli anni e ci sono ancora milioni
di bambini che muoiono di fame mentre
noi buttiamo sprechiamo un senso un
minimo di ritegno
il cibo è qualcosa di sacro è qualcosa
che qualcuno ha creato mettendoci ore e
ore di sacrificio ore di ricerca danari
propri quando mangiamo un prodotto
artigianale non mangiamo solo un
prodotto mangiamo un pezzettino della
vita di questa persona i civili hanno
un'anima quando sono prodotti con quella
famosa parola che si chiama amore
noi non possiamo dimenticarci di questo
perché noi siamo questi qui vi ricordate
a scuola che piantavamo i fagiolini di
nel crotone per capire come nascevano le
piante e invece oggi siamo gli stessi
che in freezer abbiamo gli spinaci a
cubetti tutti lo spinacio cubetto non
esiste perché dopo io posso farvi una
domanda semplice cemento e mangiato una
pasta ripiena ricotta e spinaci giusto
quante volte avete sentito davvero il
gusto degli spinaci perche sono gia
bolliti sono congelati gli ori bolliti
nell'acqua gli altri stati in uno
straccio li facevo passare sotto le
gomme di un tir e nella stessa cosa e
rapisce politico
noi non ci possiamo dimenticare chi
siamo e da dove veniamo non possiamo
nasconderci dietro un dito
non possiamo ingozzarci di finto sushi a
16 euro e 90 siamo italiani abbiamo un
paese meraviglioso prodotti meravigliosi
abbiamo insegnato al mondo la pizza la
mozzarella gli spaghetti
non possiamo essere proprio noi a
dimenticarci chi siamo e di solito
quando raccolto queste cose agli
spettacoli quando mi chiedo perché il
latte sardo viene rovesciato dentro le
fogne cosa che mi piange il cuore
la risposta di solito è sì però io a
casa non ho tempo
forse ci viene in aiuto un pochettino
stock di prima
io penso che noi crediamo di non avere
tempo perché sappiate un italiano
medio cosa fa tutti i giorni circa
un'ora e mezza due ore al giorno si fa i
cavoli degli altri su facebook sempre
allora la mia domanda è ma possiamo noi
andare a togliere mezz'ora è per
mezz'oretta solo di tempo a instagram ea
facebook per cucinare una caccia per
possiamo togliere quella mezz'oretta per
fare il giro è anche conoscere se non
conosciamo i contadini della zona gli
artigiani della zona andare a prendere
un frutto di stagione
insegnare ai nostri bimbi di mettere giù
l'ipad cinque minuti anche quello cinque
minuti e andare a rubare alle ciliegie
matura al contadino
io lo facevo sempre da una valanga disco
peggiori ma è meraviglioso perché questi
gusti che rimangono impressi talmente
installati nella testa che poi quando ti
danno della robaccia te ne accorgi
subito non possiamo arrivare al punto
che l'olio tartufato è più buono di
quello vero non l'ho certo fatto non
esiste perché aromatizzare un litro di
tartufo ci vogliono circa 100 gr di olio
c'è una circa 100 grammi di tartufo cosa
costerà mai un bollettino da 200 ml 5
euro e 50 con lo scontro soci è
impossibile perché cos'è allora questo
olio tartufato è una rom ha sintetizzato
in laboratorio che assomiglia vagamente
a l'odore di certo forma di tartufo non
c'è niente zero attenzione
informiamoci le informazioni ci sono
dappertutto
non possiamo dimenticarci diciamo io vi
chiedo aiuto e ne approfitterò per
questo perché da solo non riesco a fare
niente non ce la faccio
ma noi abbiamo un grande potere nelle
mani è il potere di scegliere non ci
facciamo fregare dalle super pubblicità
del draghetto verde o dai mari aperti
puliti
noi abbiamo la possibilità di scegliere
un prodotto made in italy piuttosto che
un prodotto di stagione
il prodotto allevato con criterio questo
per il bene nostro per il bene della
nostra storia e io sono convinto che ce
la facciamo
se tutti insieme diamo il nostro
contributo ce la facciamo perché questa
non è la fine
questo è solo l'inizio grazie
[Applauso]